a new national suicide and crisis
lifeline is set to launch tomorrow with
the goal of expanding mental health
treatment in the united states people
will be able to call or text 988
text or call 988. you'll be able to do
that 24 hours a day seven days a week
they will connect with counselors for
general mental health concerns and
crises the previous 11 digit national
suicide lifeline will still work but
experts hope the shorter number will
make care more accessible jeff pigues
looks at the benefits and the possible
challenges
a lot of people have these same concerns
and i'm glad you called today this is an
example of what you will hear
when you dial 988. starting tomorrow it
will become the new national suicide and
crisis hotline and easy to remember
lifeline
for those dealing with mental health
challenges and crisis in the u.s we are
here at 24 7.
so we answered the phones all you know
all the time erica turner is the chief
clinical officer at community crisis
services one of about 200 call-in crisis
centers in the country if you're
wondering you know whether or not you
should call i think that's an indication
that you should call more than 52
million people in the united states
identified as having a mental illness in
2020 but only 46 percent received
treatment meanwhile the national suicide
rate has jumped nearly 30 percent since
2000
experts say the new three-digit number
will provide a simpler way to get
emergency care
jameson brill is the call center
director our workers work with them to
process what's going on that's brought
them to the crisis state that they're in
help them and help them identify means
of staying safe if they're having
thoughts of suicide the 11 digit suicide
prevention hotline takes in more than 3
million calls and messages a year
with the new three digit number
volume is expected to more than double
by next july we want to for people to
know that it's okay to call we want
people to know that it's okay to you
know have feelings to be in crisis but
that expected increase in calls
is fueling concerns of staffing and
infrastructure shortages in several
states former u.s surgeon general dr
jerome adams we know for this hotline to
be successful people need not just an
easy three-digit number to call but they
need someone to actually answer that
call and they need
resources to be able to refer
individuals to
we know that's not in place in a lot of
the united states the biden
administration and congress are taking
steps to help increasing federal
investments to 432 million dollars 282
million to scale up crisis centers
nationwide and 150 million as part of
the bipartisan safer communities act to
amplify the new 988 hotline but if we
don't build out the infrastructure and
and provide the funding for people to be
able to get the services that they need
then uh ultimately this could be a
failure moving forward and we don't want
that to happen one goal of the new
number is to lessen the burden on 9-1-1
and provide an alternative for those
fearful of involving police
as police officers are often not trained
to deal with mental health crises
according to the treatment advocacy
center people with untreated mental
illness
are 16 times more likely to be killed by
law enforcement ninety percent of the
time were able to de-escalate the risk
in their in the crisis over the phone dr
john draper is the executive director of
the mental health lifeline a person is
in mental health crisis
getting a an ambulance or getting a
a police response is not a calming
sort of response what many of them need
is somebody to come to them who
understands listens and helps them get
to a safer place
and so the hope is that 988 i have to
get used to saying that number
works in tandem with 9-1-1 with trained
counselors assessing the calls and then
if necessary passing them along to
emergency services or local crisis
centers and the goal is that police
don't get involved
only if there is a clear and present
danger to somebody's life
vlad 988 jeff i like what erica turner
said if you are wondering about calling
it probably means that you should call
for people that need help jeff pigues
thank you very much my friend appreciate
it